if we choose to innovate and disrupt
ourselves we can never be disrupted I
love that I doubt myself and I hope I
never stop no matter how much you chase
your passion and live your purpose and
will still be things you have to do on a
daily basis that you don't find
interesting the motivation watch a top
10 that would believe nation what's that
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew in today's lessons from a man
who went from being bullied as a child
for being overweight and nerdy to
becoming a monk and traveling across
India and Europe to now be one of the
most viewed people on the Internet he's
Jay Shetty and here's my take on his top
10 rules a success vol 5
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one build the mini dream first how do
you know your dream is your dream how do
you go after something that you don't
know if it's actually meant for you or
not great question I think the number
one thing to do is to build the mini
dream first so before trying to go off
on this huge journey of building this
humongous dream build the mini version
of it and see what it feels like so if
you want to be someone who travels
across the world and performs travel to
one city and perform if you want to be
someone who's in movies go and film a
short movie write like go and build the
mini version of that dream because that
many dreams gonna teach you so much like
I'll give you an example I know so many
people who say to me I want to be an
actor and I'll be like ok great well
let's make a short movie and when they
make a short movie and they realize
they're up at 5 a.m. every day and that
they're in the studio or on a set to
10:00 p.m. and they realize this set is
not very glamorous that they realize
they have to say the same line 30 times
before the director says that line is
okay if it lasted only actors anymore
because what we've fallen in love with
is what the dream looks like and not
what the dream is so my biggest advice
to anyone including myself has always
been build the mini dream and the mini
dream will teach you everything you need
to know about whether you're ready for
the big dream it's the same as sports if
you want to be a sports player wake up
at 4 a.m. every day go to the gym for
two hours a day like do the actual
schedule do the actual process of the
person who's already doing it so I
always say look at what people were
doing when they were at your age not on
the stage the right now and do that and
see whether you love that that's how you
figure it out just on a very small level
rule number two follow your intention
I've talked to people who've succeeded
and and they all seem to have this idea
of intention mm-hmm this idea of I'm
gonna think about you know where I'm
going with my life have a plan some
people call it goal settings sure and I
just wonder if you had
that in mind that this was sort of a
step towards something else my genuine
response to that is I wanted to be among
for the rest of my life because I fought
I thought that would be my best point of
service so my intention was to serve and
to give knowledge and to give wisdom and
to give insight by studying and going
through the growth myself but it was to
do it as a monk like did I ever think I
would be on videos in social media or
even sitting with you here today no did
I ever imagined and vision a path for me
to be moving to LA or living in the u.s.
know like those one and I speak about
the often it's interesting I talked
about how I I never really had a vision
board I never had that goal I just had a
deep intention that I wanted to learn
and share that knowledge I didn't know
what that looked like I didn't know how
it would work and I didn't have a
step-by-step process mm-hmm I just knew
that that deeply was where I wanted to
start from rule number three reinvent
yourself it's incredible the amount of
individuals in institutions and
businesses that have absolutely being
destroyed overnight because people at
the top believed and the way they've
done it for decades is the way that they
shouldn't build in the future
good again remember you can't get
anywhere new if you're always doing the
old it's just not possible one of my
favorite examples is about this company
that had the biggest market share they
had this opportunity to buy an upcoming
business that business at the time was
valued at around 50 million dollars this
large company could have bought this
small company for 50 million dollars
they said no they turned it down they
didn't believe that streaming and online
movies with the future that big company
was blockbuster and the little company
was Netflix it's incredible now when we
live in a world where Netflix it's
valued at tens of
millions of dollars and blockbuster
doesn't even exist anymore
it's incredible how many individuals
institutions and businesses have had to
completely shift transform transition
and reinvent redefine and recreate
themselves to remain relevant and this
is a great message for all of us we
don't have to change who we are
or we have to redefine reinvent and
recreate our focus our skills our
priorities our abilities we always have
to recognize how what we have is
relevant for the modern world and all
the new challenges that come with it if
we choose to innovate and disrupt
ourselves we can never be disrupted if
we choose to challenge an experiment and
test and try new things
then there's no one else who can do that
for us rule number four smile scientists
have known for some time that changing
your body through actions like smiling
sitting up straight and relaxing can
change your mental and emotional
responses when we change our body to sit
up straight to smile to connect with
others to engage with presence we
automatically change the responses in
our mind we allow ourselves to feel
better to think better and to live
better
it's incredible to know that simple
changes in our body language in the way
that we're sitting can impact our
emotional mood States so much more
insightful research has been done into
this space but if you can just take a
simple step today to change your posture
to add a smile and to relax a little
you'll see how much your mind will be at
ease rule number five doubt yourself you
seem to be someone with great confidence
and and and wisdom at your young age and
I wonder are there moments when you
doubt yourself when you think well this
isn't right or I you know am i doing the
right thing or am I am i creating the
right message today hugely and I think
that that's a practice that I hope I
never lose because I think that's the
practice that makes you want to learn
more it makes you want to refine your
message and it also stops you from
putting
content for pressure so I think we live
in the world especially on social media
where there's such a pressure to put out
content volume and to keep up with
everyone else's videos and numbers going
up in views and for me that checking
system that you just spoke about that's
what helps me step back and go do I
really believe this or did it just sound
good for a moment and so I hope I always
keep that that doubt I find it as a
valuable tool and I'm always going
around in that process I had that
recently where I've really got offered
book deals from everywhere I could have
ever dreamed of after my first video and
viral and I've resisted signing with
anyone because my personal goal is to
write a book that I actually believe in
and not write there just because it's
going to sell well and so a lot of
people are like you're taking too long
you know but I'm just like but it's a
book like people are gonna pay money and
spend their time to read this book the
content has to have substance yeah and I
have to really feel like I've crafted
something of value hmm so I love that I
love that I doubt myself and I hope I
never stop rule number six increase your
attraction we spend over forty seven
percent of our time when the browsing
the internet or our mobile phones
procrastinating and we check our phones
around eighty six times per day put your
hand up if you check it more than that
so it's no surprise that we all face
distraction we all experience
distraction we're all played by
distraction but often we think that the
opposite of distraction is focus we
think that we need to become more
focused we think that if we're focused
we'll feel less distracted we feel that
if we're able to draw our energy in a
certain direction and force ourselves to
absorb in an activity then we won't be
as distracted but this is just not true
the opposite of distraction is actually
not focus the opposite of distraction is
wait for it
attraction let me explain what I mean
when we're attracted to something we
completely fixated we're completely
absorbed
we are almost addicted and obsessed to
that visual that song what we really
need to do is increase our attraction
when we are attracted to something when
naturally focused we're naturally able
to be present we're naturally able to
bring our attention and our energy to
that task that project that person when
we're distracted and don't have that
attraction we're naturally all over the
place we end up feeling lost confused
and end up procrastinating as you can
see we are procrastinating and
distracting others so now know you're
thinking how do you get attracted to
things that you're not attracted to we
all have things in life that we love to
do and we all have things in life that
we have to do let's take the example of
your job it's something that you have to
do it's something that you may not be
attracted to when you ask yourself why
do I go to my job maybe the answer is it
pays my bills maybe the answer is it
allows me to take care of my family
maybe you studied for years and feel
that your job at least engages you for
that whichever one your answer is that
starts providing some value to why you
do that activity when you know that you
recognize that you are attractive to be
there because it serves a particular
purpose you start become attracted
because whenever your mind says to you
I'm bored I'm distracted I'm unfocused
you say no I'm here because it puts food
on the table I'm here because it pays my
bills and takes care of my family I'm
here because I studied and worked hard
for this you are able to increase your
attraction to even the things you're
totally unfocused on now if you found
yourself distracted on focus for too
long that definitely can mean you need
to find more meaningful fulfilling work
but no matter what you do no matter how
much you chase your passion and live
your purpose there will still be things
you have to do on a daily basis that you
don't find interesting and not
you will feel unfocused and distracted
for that ask yourself this question why
am I here why am I doing this and you'll
find the mind will start to become
attracted to that activity task or even
that person rule number seven serve this
two-year-old girl was watching a cartoon
in her parents living room at one point
one of the cartoon characters started to
cry you can actually see the tears
coming out of their eyes this young girl
grabbed a tissue from the living room
walked up to the television and started
to wipe the screen trying to wipe the
tear of this cartoon character it was an
incredible show of kindness compassion
empathy and love from this two-year-old
girl she truly believed that the cartoon
character was crying and that her with
the tissue would be able to wipe away
its tears it was one of the most
beautiful things I've ever seen and that
was when I realized that we're wired for
generosity but educated for greed when
we're young we have this energy to give
to serve to be compassionate to be
loving to be kind but as we go through
life when we're faced with people being
extremely challenging when we're faced
with manipulation when we're faced with
people we don't trust that also makes us
close up I gotta pick a cabinet to hurt
him what can you do today that could
make a difference in someone else's life
what could you say to someone today that
would absolutely change their week or
their year what is the one thing you can
do that can truly change the experience
of even just one person on the planet Oh
think about it my favorite quote from
Muhammad Ali is that service to others
is the rent we pay for our room here on
earth rule number eight be a storyteller
are you a motivational speaker is that
what you do I like to call myself a
storyteller because I feel what I'm
trying to do is tell the stories that we
all live and I was just sharing with you
earlier that I genuinely believe that
the answers that people are looking for
inside of them and I'm just helping
people excavate and become
archaeologists and and kind of dig in
and find that through them so I don't
call myself a motivational speaker
because people may watch my videos and
it may not be motivational may be
reflective it may be introspective it
may be insightful it may be emotional it
may even take people to a place they
don't want to go so I love being sharing
my stories as a storyteller simply what
I do is make wisdom go viral I have this
fascination with wisdom insight deep
thought and I believe that that wisdom
belongs to each and every person on the
planet yeah and so my desire is to scale
that through entertainment through
storytelling through video in a way that
wisdom becomes accessible relevant and
completely involved and engaged in
people's daily lives rule number nine
recognize that you're an instrument and
there's a beautiful story of Benjamin
Franklin that he had his 13 princess
before he died he had 13 qualities that
he wanted to attain in life before he
passed away they included things like
integrity simplicity honesty virtue etc
and at the end of his life he was asked
which one they do not attain and he said
the 13th one and they said what was that
is a humility the reason why I'm sharing
that story is because the way you
overcome your ego is to recognize that
you're simply a channel or an instrument
when you recognize that your instrument
and whether you believe in the universe
whether you believe in power or whether
you just believe in mentorship you
recognize that everything you're giving
is because someone's given to you and
someone's given to that person and
therefore you're becoming a vessel an
instrument of vehicle for the greatest
powers in the world and just being a
channel for that and that allows you to
pull through things one thing is you
feel liberated because now it's no
longer your burden the second thing that
it does is that it allows you whenever
your ego gets in the winces yeah
well like I did that I did like you
start recognizing and you get
perspective gratitude in the fact that
no actually I'm gonna pass this whatever
Goods happening my life pass it to my
teachers pass it to the people that
shared it with me because there is no
one who is self-made we took what
self-made millionaires there is no one
that weren't even exist yeah because no
one none of us is so made I'm not
self-made you're right all I'm saying is
just that if we all truly reflect and we
go I don't want to be anyone watching to
think I have to be self-made
because if you after yourself made then
you're gonna have to self all - yeah
right and everything will be self self
self when you fall on your own and you
rise on your own and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is choose change over regret
[Applause]
healing is so not about getting over
stuff and it's so much about getting
through stuff and I think we have this
mental block in thinking I need to get
over this rather they get through it and
when you try and get over something you
don't necessarily process the pain you
don't necessarily give yourself the time
and the energy and the care to express
how you fell and allow yourself a outlet
to really let go yeah and that's coming
from the point of view realizing that
regret is painful change is painful but
change is less painful than regret and
so when you realize that actually the
only two options I have now I regret or
change and they both hurt but change
hurts less and when we recognize that
then we choose to change we choose to
move forward we choose to let go of that
regret because we realize that regrets
not serving us
now I've got a really special bonus gift
from Jay on how to have a mission that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
taking action and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one how will
you choose change over regret number two
how will you serve others better and
number three what intention of yours do
you need to follow
my goal has never been financially or
materially oriented I see that stuff as
a byproduct of doing what you love I
genuinely genuinely believe that it's
always been that way around for me my
focus is to create entertainment that
truly has educational value but without
always knowing it I think we all learn
best when we don't know that we're
learning if we're all pushed into a
classroom and told we have a class we're
all not listening but if you're sitting
back and watching TV but you learn
something fascinating that blows our
mind so my focus is on building the
biggest production company the biggest
pictures house that's able to create
cultural and meaningful shifts through
media in a way that we're being
entertained but we're growing at the
same time because that way it becomes
effortless that way it becomes simple
and that way becomes natural and
learning becomes part of our natural
day-to-day we don't now need to
disappear or go away to have that same
journey so that's my desire is to keep
making wisdom go viral through TV
entertainment media podcasts audio any
form that people are consuming because I
feel that if we can switch people from
consuming mind-numbing content to
mind-blowing content then that simple
transition will will change people's
lives without them even knowing you
if you want more jay Shetty check out
the first top 10 rules video I made on
him I think you'll enjoy the link is
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there thank you
so much for featuring my ideas and my
thoughts I've been following you for a
long long time so I'm really excited to
see this come together